Крим за три дні Ну знаєш як Київ за три
дні але ні між тим було 8 років і
ключові були 14-19 рік коли насправді
політика національної ідентичності вона
стала базою Да ми викинули в освіті
російську мову Пригадайте до 14-го року
Хто в нас героями в телевізорі постійним
був російський Вибачте російське
кіно було заборонено і російські
інформаційні програми були заборонені і
Україна творила власний культурний
простір і власне інформаційний простір і
власне музичний простір і звичайно
українці почали себе ідентифікувати з
Україною і якраз це спричинило спротив і
оце треба аналізувати що тоді було
зроблено насправді І що тоді от в цей
час який нам дали Мінські угоди
підготувати от знаєте те що всередині і
те що в голові спосіб мислення спосіб
відчуття усвідомлення власної
ідентичності